robert spencer al-qaeda you remember
them from 9 11 is threatening the united
states now
in open
uh conflict
with attacks that are going to be more
painful than 9 11.
is that possible what do you know
well it's certainly possible barry for
one thing we know that the uh
hijackers who were with al qaeda on
september 11 2001 where did they train
afghanistan
and
now
the taliban which allowed them
to allowed al-qaeda to establish
training camps in afghanistan is back in
power
meanwhile
there are thousands of unvetted unknown
afghan refugees are already in the
country
not long before
the planes out of kabul started being
loaded up
the taliban released the the prisoners
who were in bagram prison at bagram air
base who were isis and al qaeda members
so an unknowable number
of isis and al qaeda members could have
been among those who came to the united
states it only took 19 to kill nearly 3
000 people on 9 11.
and we've got 12 000 afghans that biden
administration officials have admitted
we have no idea who they are and they're
already in the country
so the consequences could be quite
literally explosive
you